uh you know and you guys as we get into  the holiday spirit  we just wanted to give another shout out  to our nate tannenbaum who's all festive  this morning  here he is oh tana tannenbaum  all year long hi nate thank you  you can't escape us even at your house  no that's okay are you selling cardboard  cutouts of yourself with lights with  decorated lights you should you know  uh maybe if opportunity village made  them i would i would look into it yeah  all right  now i have an ornament here but i don't  have pierced ears so this this won't  hang  off my ear don't put that on your ear  just use the one that linda builds right  here  i can't use that one  hi linda it's a family show it's a  family show  i'm kidding i'm just kidding